welcome. Um, so
the talk is building on ACP on uh at
OpenCloud. It's uh also about other
things like how to uh put open source
agents on open source agent frameworks
on Kubernetes and stuff. So I'm I'm I
hope uh to I will today share in a nice
way what I've been working on in the
last two months. Um a little bit about
me very brief my ah a little bit about
me. I've been building harnesses since a
few months before chat GPD came out. I
built a Jupyter lab extension over OG
codeex model like Dainci code 2 um back
in the days that eventually so I'm
currently working for a startup and that
that initial coding harness turned into
its current harness over time like a
ship of thesis it got ripped apart and
put back together so many times and uh
yeah I'm a founding engineer there I've
been uh in the industry since three and
a half four years I using open clause
since cloudbot uh first dropped in
discord. I went in there. I've been
following Peter since he wrote uh cloud
code is my computer. I was like this guy
is crazy
because uh cloud force on it like I
wouldn't give my machine to it but he he
went he ventured forth and he's paved
the way for us and when I saw uh
cloudbot in discord my mind was blown.
The next day I installed it uh at the
company uh in our like cluster and it
was basically talking to people on
discore and also everybody else's minds
were blown and we are like we have we're
used to selling the enterprise for a few
uh years now. So that's why I started by
adding an MS teams integration in case
it might be useful at some point and I
became a maintainer along the way. I was
there when it was renamed two times. Um
and today I I'm my focus is on agent
interoperability and orchestration.
Um like one of my goals is accelerate
enterprise adoption of openlow and
adjacent software and also address you
know open glow is not secure. Well it
will be secure or Peter talked a lot
about that earlier so I don't have
anything else to add on top of it like
it's work in progress.
Sorry,
I'll use this.
So, uh started by I started on developer
workflows right away. So, I created a PR
uh and then call it Discord driven
development. Well, Telegram driven
development suits better because it's
TDD. So um and then uh right after I set
it personally and I realized you know
oppus is not so reliable for complex it
wasn't back in the days it's now better
it's agents are improving but codex was
main my main harness and I wanted to use
codex in discord but it was basic I was
telling I was playing a telephone game I
was telling us to tell codex to do
something god knows what it's saying you
know because wording matters when
prompting but it was working somehow and
I would go uh and then look at the codec
session and then it paraphrased kind of
what I was saying but eventually you
know u I got some stuff done but I knew
this could be done much easier um
and today I'm running a full ID on
discord like uh you know we have
parallel workloads you have like one to
like five channels at any point I'm
working with one to five agents um so
you see codeex one to and then close is
for testing the open close ACP feature
and then yeah basically that's how my
some of my channels look like and it's
very good for coding on the go because I
have I'm a guy who's addicted to side
projects and uh I I like to just you
know uh AI is making things a making
things a lot easier to do these sort of
things like in parallel you have an
inspiration you execute on a weekend and
you just get it ready you ship it ACPX
which I'm going to talk about is is like
similar. I built it through uh discord
and what you do is you bind the channel
uh discord channel to codex through ACP.
You can also use codex app server
protocol. Harold, another maintainer,
uh, developed it and here is me using it
before I flying to London to create an
PDF about like convert the docs of ACP
into PDF and then I have to say put it
in temp because open codex doesn't know
about the harness and it cannot send me
in discord. So then I go to another
channel and tell it to send it to me on
that channel. So we are developers and
our tools we don't have time to polish
them very well but we know the
like advantages and disadvantages. What
is ACP? So it's not most people say is
it like MCP? MCP for is for giving tools
to the model. ACP is for uh like
standardizing agent to client
interaction. It's uh shout out to Zed. I
actually forgot to put Zed logo. Um
Zed is building a new editor in Rust
more efficient like lower memory usage
not electron. So uh I'm using that also
since like uh last fall and uh you know
if you use codex on VS code or cloud
code they are all building different
plugins. It's not exactly it's like so
much wasted work. If only you could just
standardize them under one interface and
you just build it once and then you you
ship it. And that's what the the idea
that's the idea they had. is also more
it's it's much less duplicate duplicated
work. Um there are competing standards.
Um so agent like agent uh agent protocol
that's for agent talking to agent. ACP
agent client protocol is for a human
talking to agent but agent can use the
human one to talk to other agents as
well. In the long run as as these
protocols get adopted we will support
all of them. they will weigh the you
know advantages and then we will use
them somehow but when I need so I chose
ACP because when I needed the most I
needed adapters for codecs and cloud
code and only zed had built them and
Google didn't have them back back back
at the time so that's why I chose it
u that so I when you're adding in
functionality to open claw you do uh you
use do it through a CLI
Um
so I said okay let's create a CLI for
ACP let's an agent call any other agent
over the command line. So that's that's
how it started. Uh and it's slowly
turning into a Swiss army knife for ACP
as I will show in a bit.
So in uh at openlow you have fire hoses
uh we have 60 kprs uh over 60 kprs total
300 to 500 per day on average are open
and basically overnight people woke up
and decided they want they like open. So
we have tens of thousands of
stakeholders who want to add features to
open cloud and the biggest challenge of
the project currently is how do you uh
absorb all the needs and wants of these
people and how do you balance them? How
do you like you can't please everyone
but how do you create an elegant system
without uh creating AI slop
that can cater everyone's needs and
Peter's workflow uh gave me an idea so
this is also something I do you go and
you ask your clanker what is this so PR
comes your way like most of the time
it's AI generated description like what
is this uh if the human put thought into
it, great. But like, yeah, you need to
ask what it's doing. You ask what is
this the best possible fix. Most of the
time it's no. And then you either
continue disc like he he wrote it like
you you do some back and forth with the
agent. The reason is people just uh run
into an issue with their open claw and
it can use GitHub and then they just say
uh please fix and then they just send
some slop your way. You know this is you
can't merge it but you can also fully
discard. You need to take this data
point you it's like crucial feedback
from the user. Uh so you need to put it
categorize it put it in a bin you know
it it tells you when some part of the
code is broken and Vincent also talked
about that a bit uh and here is uh his
his codeex session doing that on one
side there's a one that says it's it's a
good fix. Uh, and the on other side is
just saying it's not bad. And yeah, this
is so mechanical and you you once you do
this over and over, you realize you're
repeating something. If only you could
program something to automate it. So
you're automating the automator. Um, so
I created I started uh to create like
workflows uh in an abstract way. So uh
item comes PR and then you find the
intent you're judging implementation
you're like uh looking in if has
conflicts uh if reviews gives you like
some issues that need to be addressed so
you need to make the CI pass if it's not
passing already most people just don't
care about that all this mechanical work
by the time the m the PR ends up in
front of you should be resolved ideally
and can be resolved and that's what I'm
working on
ah in the workflow we have the shameful
uh Ralph review refactor loops uh I I'm
a believer that you know when people say
like give the
just just run a running a agent in a
loop does not not necessarily have to be
a uh something that will create slope as
long as you're not making it design
something but you're making it uncover
shallow bugs that can be easily fixed
should be fine. So in the abstract
workflow that I created u which is
actually called like pro like turn into
a program you can uh tell it to uh do
superficial refactors and then you can
tell if it's it needs a fundamental
refactor relate to the human um
resolving conflicts also doesn't need
like no it was hard back in the days I
don't think anyone is like resolving
conflicts by hand by now um so we are
basically creating uh standard operating
procedures for agents is a fancy word
for workflow. Um so that's what I built
into ACPX. Uh it's a N10 like workflow
engine. Uh but it's driving a codeex
session. You can see on the right. Let
me show you in action.
So this was one PR.
It's loading. Uh let's speed it up a
bit. So there's some programmatic parts.
So this is just replaying uh what it's
doing.
Uh it's reproducing the bug. It's
judging refactor. It's reviewing. Now
I'm doing a review loop and then review
didn't uh bring anything. It it's it's
what I do. Uh but I make it outputs like
JSON structured data. So I can put in
like an anon like workflow and I will
talk you know this is a general workflow
engine. Um you can use it on other
things as well.
Um like you need to apply agents
generously
on problems. So I see it is like an
ointment uh that you apply generously on
any problem that can be solved with
agents. You need to take yourself out of
the loop and solve it with agents. Um
and personal agents I think uh are on a
like there there's a spectrum enterprise
and personal agent and normally you see
you know the the work you use at the
computer and then the PC the the PC you
use at work and the PC you use at at the
home used to be relatively similar but
that will not be the case with agents
because at at work you will be using
consuming a lot more inference uh and
that means in enterprise there will a
lot more money to be made. So that's why
I'm a bit also excited about enterprise
agents and open close potential.
That's why uh I I believe in uh on
demand disposable agents. If you use
openclaw on slack or teams or discord is
one instance you create an app. The
problem is you can't really talk to
multiple instances of this. um
like
you create a connection, you create a
Slack app to connect another agent and
another name and another uh profile
picture you need to create another app
and you have to create an app manifest
and it's it's it's something that
shouldn't be managed manually by
clicking and the platforms like chat
apps don't have this standard yet where
you can mult do multi- aent provisioning
like cosmetically create different
agents. This is what this is on on the
screen. You see I asked chat GP to gen
generate the idea. You agents uh and
then the name can be generated by an
underlying app and you can talk to them
separately. This is not supported and
this must be supported for this uh
vision to work until it's supported. I'm
using it on another UI because like we
are all gonna start one uh agent per
task and there will be uh they will work
on these tasks and they will be creating
files, editing files and it will all be
synchronized. It will be it will be a
tad bit different than what you're used
to with your uh personal agent. And to
do to have that you need to have like a
few key components. You need to have
Kubernetes. You need to uh have an agent
harness. Open cloud could be one of
them. Codex cloud code could be one of
them. Could be ACP. It could be uh
GitHub.
uh you give read write access and you do
like state data synchronization like you
maybe you do something that's use rync
some something like what whatever
algorithm Dropbox is using and there are
some projects that are uh taking this on
I've been working on this uh this is
outside of openlow this is my day job
and uh it's an open source uh
orchestrator
uh it's a go operator that's uh
basically handles
the complicated parts. You know, there's
a user experience. You want to create a
concierge on Slack like concier agent
and you're talking to it, but you get
bottleneck because you have 100
employees on Slack. So, you need to for
for some other task you may you may need
to create a new one and then it creates
and gives you like a website link. Um,
I'm going to skip the like shout outs to
Cognition and Devon uh because uh yeah,
they invented the category, but I'm
running low on time. So, the repo is a
text cortex spritz. I'm just going to
demo it for our use case. We use it on
error reporting. Uh currently, so if
you're on Slack, you know, you can ask
it to dispatch an agent to debug it. you
know, you're like, I'm uh asking any new
bugs after pro release and it's saying
something and then you ask it to create
an agent. Well, if I could put that
agent into Slack, I would, but I can't
do that. So, I have to put it in another
UI. And this is an open source project.
You can take this UI is also uh like a
React app hosted in the cluster that
you're deploying this these Helm charts
to. And uh yeah you it starts the
conversation there. It starts working on
the uh problem. This is like codex web
or devon or anything but it's actually
using like a full kubernetes pod
wasteful but I think it's the better
abstraction because open close showed
the power you know when you give a full
computer to an agent it's a lot more
powerful. Um and I I believe that as
well. um u like I think uh open hands
uses firecracker so I'm also uh not so
uh wellversed on all the different
virtualization frameworks uh so it's I'm
also learning along the way but I have a
working product that's uh running on
kubernetes
uh and you can use this uh product uh
you can if you're interested in
deploying internally and uh using codex
on the
uh and then you just spin things off. If
you have like I don't know a back end uh
if if you have an open source project
first of all I can help you set this up.
If you have a system like inlet of just
hundred of hundreds of issues per day I
can help you process it. Um this is um
does all the wiring around Slack and
like keeping those agents uh like on and
the user experience and then the the
interro like you're not locked in in any
agent you can switch it's all abstract
the way bel uh with ACP yeah that was my
talk uh thank you for listening some
social links in case you want to uh get
in contact with me I just want to clear
like of my uh their open uh side and the
text cortex site. Um so this the last
part was text about the work I do at
text cortex.
Just to give a disclaimer
um thank you for listening I guess.
Heat. Heat.